so it's interesting because feminists
have asked for equal treatment for
decades yet when it is given to them
they cry about it so there is a video
talking about how men should never hit
women let's pull it up cuz men should
never hit a woman why
not that's just up what why why should a
man hit a woman to protect
himself oh man this isn't this is a lot
what do you mean I just disagree with
your viewpoints why that you you think a
man should hit a woman should a woman
hit him yes I do I don't think violence
is the answer to anything no in
protection he's
self-defense let's say a woman he
shouldn't just go around Hing just for
no reason yeah but let's say that should
women hit men no right so if a woman
should hit a man she need smack her back
no why not cuz she's a girl well she
doesn't know
that uh but I just think that's unfair
so if a woman smack a man what she to
do he probably deserved it to be honest
what yeah you want to play this game
let's go and doesn't she deserve to be
smacked back if she no she's a girl girl
guys should not hit girls but girls
should hit guys I never said that no but
if they do the GU should smack a back no
why not cuz guys shouldn't hit girls why
cuz it's it's just that's that's just
unfair how because girls are tender and
beautiful creatures that should not be
hit but don't think know that before
they hit the man that they can't handle
it I don't know it's interesting how
whenever women do something wrong it's
like the default blame men well he
probably deserved it did he for what
women are tender and Beautiful Creatures
are they they're more likely to kill
infants than the elderly and you know
what's interesting whenever I try to
find something that women are better at
I've just noticed it's always something
that can't be measured that's like an
intangible I I never get an actual
anyways um you know feminists ask for
equality here you go equal rights equal
lefts baby and I actually agree I I
think of a woman hits a man girl you
you're gonna get your rocked I I I
didn't tell you to do that I don't I
don't hit men I don't do that so if you
choose to do that then don't come crying
to me when you get a black eye when you
get your when you get you know I I'll
beat up and you're going to keep seeing
cases in the news where you see these
you know these guys die because they
were told they can never hit back you
know it's interesting cuz a lot of
abusive women blame the abuse on the men
when really a lot of times um they were
protecting themselves and I found this
out actually when I started doing
shows um my default was always just to
believe people you know what I mean like
when someone gives you a story of
something traumatic that they went
through your your gut reaction isn't to
say I don't believe you or ask them all
these questions but one day a girl was
talking and someone someone in the
comment said ask her if she filed a
police
report and the answer was no and I said
okay tell me specifically what happened
and you know the more the story
unraveled The more she said everything
um you know one one girl told
me that her ex pushed her like down or
like shoved her on the ground something
like that and it turns out that she was
trespassing this woman wouldn't leave
this man's house and then was mad that
he kicked her out I mean how else was he
supposed to get you to leave and and
this is the problem is that women are
told we can do virtually whatever we
want with no consequences